hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
since the dawn of civilization mankind
has always looked up at the heavens and
wondered what lay beyond our planet
while most people gazed in wonder only a
select few have ever visited space
the tale of the first man to do so is a
story of triumph Fame a sad demise and
some very peculiar events to understand
what happened let me tell you a story on
October 4th 1957 humans would send an
object into space for the first time in
history the Soviet satellite Sputnik 1
became the first artificial object to be
put in orbit a Sputnik was a brief
mission sending out a radio signal phony
22 days before burning up in the
atmosphere in early 1958 it would make a
pass around the earth once every 96
minutes and the world was stunned by the
event the launch of Sputnik was a much
more significant event than most people
today realize it prompted the foundation
of NASA and DARPA by the Americans
marking the beginning of the space race
but Sputnik will also result in the
Americans forming ARPANET the start of
our current Internet
the world was absolutely shocked when
the Russians sent Sputnik into space but
the USSR wasn't finished on April 12
1961 aboard the spacecraft Vostok 1 27
year-old cosmonaut Yuri Gagarin became
the first team in to travel into space
Vostok 1 orbited the planet for just 89
minutes at a maximum altitude of 320
kilometers it was basically a cannonball
large enough for one person it was
guided entirely by an automatic control
system Yuri Gagarin wasn't very
talkative during the ordeal some of his
only words were quote flight is
proceeding normally I am well he said
these words while traveling at 29,000
kilometers an hour or eight kilometers
per second
upon his return Gagarin became an
instant worldwide celebrity in Russia he
ascended to legendary status monuments
were raised and street names were
changed throughout the Soviet Union in
his honor at this time the United States
were just being beaten to the punch
they'll being punched square in the face
to add insult to injury in August of
1962 the Americans were beaten again it
was another cosmonaut in the spacecraft
Vostok 2 this time orbiting 17
revolutions around the earth and
spending more than 25 hours in space
it wasn't until February of 1962 when
astronaut John Glenn made three orbits
around the earth in friendship seven
understanding that he needed to boost
his country's confidence President
Kennedy declared that the US would reach
the moon by the end of the decade we
choose to go to the moon in this decade
and do the other things not because they
are easy but because they are hard
they called that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we are willing to
accept one we are unwilling to postpone
and one we intend to win
but for now the Russians were in charge
though later our protagonist Yuri
Gagarin would find himself in a lot of
trouble
on march twenty seventh nineteen
sixty-eight seven years after his trip
to space yuri gagarin got up early in
the morning and headed to check aloft
ski airport his purpose was to retrain
as a fighter pilot after his time as a
cosmonaut the plan was for Kagura to run
a few tests missions in his Russian MIG
15 but of course things wouldn't go
according to plan the weather was poor
at the airport with the wind and rain
making their presence known
when Gagarin forgot his ID that morning
he told those around him that this was a
bad omen despite the weather and the bad
juju
Gagarin took off without incident after
he'd completed his exercises he radioed
back to base saying that he would return
shortly this would be the last time that
anyone would hear from him a couple of
hours later a flight rescue team took
off on a search mission as they were
searching they could see the planes
burning wreckage from the air the hope
was that the former cosmonaut may have
ejected before impact
unfortunately these hopes were dashed
when Gagarin's body was found the next
day an extensive investigation by the
USSR proved to be inconclusive one
prevalent theory was that Gagarin
swerved to avoid an object a bird or a
weather balloon and lost control of the
aircraft naturally being the Soviet
Union very little information was
released to the public in conspiracy
theories started to grow
some saké Agarn was drunk and decided to
take a joy flight it's not totally
unfeasible as Yuri had a history with
the bottle
the young cosmonaut had taken his
meteoric rise to international fame
fairly hard as a former village boy he
wasn't prepared to be an icon of
inspiration he would receive thousands
of letters from citizens across the USSR
telling of disturbing stories and asking
for help it was then that he began to
see the dark underbelly of the Soviet
Union as time went on this took a toll
on the young cosmonaut he began to slip
into alcoholism and other risky behavior
other theories suggest that he was a
secret agent from the CIA and was
poisoned
there was another rumor that stated that
he actually survived the plane crash and
had gone into hiding still others said
that he was trying to avoid a UFO when
he crashed so what really happened will
we ever know well you're in luck because
in 2013 the cause of the crash was
finally determined as it turns out
another much larger plane as sukhoi
su-15 came into the airspace of Gagarin
smick 15 causing him to take evasive
action and crash in the end it was a
run-of-the-mill accident ending in
tragedy the Soviet authorities and air
traffic control was so embarrassed about
their incompetence that they didn't
release the true cause of the accident
adds is that the altimeter at the
control tower wasn't not functioning
properly and there was no way of
avoiding that collision there the pilot
made a very dangerous maneuver in the
clouds only 15 meters away from the
garance plane and turned it over and
then sent it into a tailspin
at a speed of around 750 kilometers an
hour yuri gagarin said jet fighter
spiraled into the ground this is not yet
another version of the gardens death but
a true reason why we lost him when he
was only 34 years old before we finished
this episode the question has to be
asked why were the Russians so much
better than the Americans at space
travel during the 1960's
well it's largely due to the brilliance
of just one man who has been forgotten
by history
[Music]
the Soviets conquest of space was viewed
as evidence for the supremacy of
communism over capitalist however only
insiders who worked on Sputnik and the
Fasnacht programs knew that this success
was due to one man Sergei Pavlovich
Korolev the chief designer of these
programs Korolev was unknown in the West
and even to the Russian public until
after his death
Korolev helped launch the first Soviet
liquid-fueled rocket in 1933 five years
later during one of Joseph Stalin's
paranoid purges Korolev and his
colleagues were put on trial convicted
of treason and sabotage Korolev was
sentenced to 10 years in a labor camp as
World War two intensified the Soviet
leaders started to realize that German
rocket technology was a real threat
knowing of Korolev's Talent the
government put him to work from prison
in 1945 when the war was over Korolev
was sent to Germany to learn about Nazi
rocketry his mission was to study the v2
rocket it was basically an early form of
homing missile that heavily damaged the
British during the war the Americans
were also interested in this technology
they captured the v2 rockets designer
and eventually made him head of the u.s.
space program
the Soviets went further and managed to
get their hands on the Rockets
blueprints and a few German v2
technicians by 1954 Korolev had built a
rocket which could carry a 5 ton nuclear
warhead in 1957 the Russians launched
the first anakin ental ballistic missile
but Korolev had his eyes set on bigger
things which brings us back to the
launch of Sputnik 1 it was the first
Soviet victory in the space race but
amazingly Korolev was still in prison
when he worked on the project he would
finally be released a short time later
and with Korolev at the helm the Soviet
space program would be unmatched in the
early 1960s the Soviet list of firsts
into space include the first animal in
orbit first large scientific satellite
first man first woman first three men
first spacewalk first spacecraft to
impact the moon first spacecraft to
orbit the moon first spacecraft to
impact Venus and first spacecraft to
soft land on the moon
the Americans were simply no match while
Korolev was in charge
despite all his success Sergei Pavlovich
Korolev was only known by the mysterious
title of chief designer Korolev would
died in 1966 from health complications
during his mistreatment in the labor
camp upon his death his identity was
finally revealed to the world and he was
awarded a burial in a Kremlin wall as a
hero of the soviet union as good as this
was I'm sure he would have appreciated
this honor a little more when he was
still alive both Yuri Gagarin and
Korolev both advanced humanities
ventures into space and I'm sure very
few people have heard of both of their
names and that's what this video is for
to bring to light history that's been
forgotten the trend of going to space is
about to heat up again in the 2020s as
private companies from Richard Branson
Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos take to the
heavens once again we'll see all of this
in the next episode which will be the
week after next
while that episode is being made next
week I'll be releasing some music which
a lot of you have been asking for so
stay tuned for all of that in the coming
weeks and if you do want to see anything
on science technology and business and
history definitely subscribe so you
don't miss upcoming videos alright so
this has been to gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking